if PTSD is a confusing phrase I think
for a lot of people I mean first of all
it's not just something that soldiers
get it's not just something that happens
in war life's traumatic there are car
accidents children die of cancer all
kind all kinds of horrible things happen
to civilians and they wind up with a
long term traumatic reaction which is
just as crippling as what can happen to
soldiers in combat so it's important to
remember this is just the human
condition that we're talking about when
I was covering war in the 90s I had
never heard the term PTSD I didn't know
that there were long-term psychological
consequences to trauma so when I came
back from Afghanistan in 2000 I was
there a year before 9/11 with the
Northern Alliance under Ahmed Shah
Massoud and I spent two months in the
north and you know back then the Taliban
were a real military force I mean they
had fighter planes they had an Air Force
they had tanks they had everything and
so fighting the Taliban was a really
daunting proposition and we got hammered
a few times and I came back to New York
pretty altered actually but I didn't
know it I was a young man I didn't think
anything really affected me and I was
fine until one day I went down into the
subway and unexpectedly
I had the first panic attack of my life
everything was gonna kill me the trains
were going too fast and we're gonna jump
the rails and somehow plow into me there
were too many people in the platform and
they were gonna somehow turn on me and
attack me the lights were too bright
everything was too loud I knew I wasn't
in danger but it felt like I was in
enormous danger and I was absolutely
terrified and I finally ran out of there
and you know walked to wherever I was
going and and I kept having panic
attacks in small places where I was
confined and couldn't leave you know
four months later I had no idea I was
connected to combat I mean I wasn't in a
situation like that in combat so I
didn't know that they were connected but
in fact it was and I was having what's
called short term acute post-traumatic
stress disorder it's a survival
adaptation I was having all the
reactions the
you want to have if your life's been in
danger you want to react to sudden
noises you don't want to be in
situations where you're out of where you
don't have control small confined spaces
with too many people too much going on
that's a dangerous situation you want to
be a little bit depressed it keeps you
quiet and out of harm's way you want to
be quick to anger it makes you prepared
to fight all the things we associate
with PTSD have real survival value in a
situation of great danger the problem
the problem happens when that acute PTSD
turns into a long-term disorder that can
last even someone's lifetime and at that
point it doesn't have survival value it
actually has negative value I mean it
gets in the way of leading a healthy
life and that's chronic long-term PTSD
it's not adaptive it's not healthy it's
the opposite and that is the problem
that America is trying to solve with
some of its soldiers most of the US
military is not face to face with their
enemy even a topi Restrepo a combat
outpost that I said was that for off and
on for a year those guys were in an
enormous amount of combat we never once
saw the enemy they're all muzzle flashes
they got shot at
well whatever a lot of stuff was going
on there were casualties but they
actually never were they never saw the
enemy and most of the US military is not
in combat only 10% of the US military is
actually in combat but the curious thing
is that when you bring these soldiers
back to this country a much larger
percentage than 10% experience pretty
intense psychological distress
it can't be trauma because they weren't
in combat so what is it exactly if you
look at Peace Corps volunteers who
obviously aren't in war zones but
they're living in small tightly bonded
communities in the developing world and
when they come back something like 25
percent of Peace Corps volunteers go
into a serious depression soldiers even
if they weren't in combat and most
weren't soldiers experienced a very
similar communal life within their
platoon each person is essential to the
group the
is essential to each per each person it
reproduces our evolutionary past very
very closely they do everything together
the meals together they sleep in the
same area they live a communal innocence
primitive existence that feels really
good and when people come back from
circumstances like that be at the Peace
Corps or the military or what-have-you
when they return from a situation like
that to modern society it's
psychologically very very hard and the
depression rates very high soldiers call
it PTSD because that's the term that is
current in society right now but
actually and I'm not a psychologist my
guess is that a fair amount of those
people actually weren't traumatized and
and what they're actually experiencing
is a painful radical transition from
communalism to the sort of individualism
of modern society and it doesn't feel
good
drone warfare is an interesting example
of how you don't have to be in danger to
be traumatized and in fact what
researchers have found is that the most
traumatizing thing to human beings is
witnessing harm to others witnessing
dismemberment witnessing people being
killed particularly women and children
but even enemy combatants seeing harm
and dismemberment to other human beings
is extremely disturbing and I know from
my own experience the times that my life
has been in danger those incident
incidents have changed me but I wouldn't
say that they're traumatizing the things
that have really remained in my mind and
can pretty quickly bring tears to my
eyes are the times that I've seen seeing
other people suffering or are other
people dead who people who should not be
dead and civilians children that kind of
thing so now think about drone operators
you know they're in an air-conditioned
room somewhere in Nevada or at least
that's where I that's right picture them
wherever they are they're in an
air-conditioned room with a joystick
flying drones around halfway around the
world and deciding
to annihilate a group of people on the
ground they're playing God and not only
they playing God they're playing God in
a situation where they themselves are
not in danger I think on some level as
as tactically sensible as drone warfare
is on some level I think to the actual
pilots it might feel a little bit
dishonorable like you're killing people
without being in any danger yourself and
that that sense of you know is this
honorable or not actually can be that
question it can actually be kind of
traumatic no from V I know from talking
to psychologists who studied Vietnam one
of the one of the most disturbing ideas
with it was that that we might not be
fighting at an honorable war over there
and that was really that was really
disturbing to people in ways that having
a bullet go by your head isn't that
disturbing you can recover from that
pretty quickly and so for drone
operators the fact that they have an
elevated rate of PTSD they have the same
rate of PTSD as people who fly combat
missions in the arena of combat in
actual airplanes says something very
profound about humans and and and and
and in some ways it says a good thing
about humans that we're that deeply
disturbed by doing harm to others I
think she sort of allows us to see a
glimmer of hope for the human race I
often look at this country through the
eyes of soldiers who have fought for us
all and I know that out there I know
this because I've seen it out there
there are literally no distinctions of
race or politics or religion or anything
people in a platoon in combat
are valued for how they act not for
their race their beliefs whatever it may
be it's a it's a weird a Galit Aryan
utopia in that sense and they come back
to a country which is really at war with
itself soldiers fight for this country
and come back to a country that's
fighting itself and I imagine I'm not a
vet so I don't know firsthand but I
imagine that is incredibly demoralizing
if you have political parties political
leaders who are literally accusing each
other of being an enemy of the state of
actively trying to harm this country you
have people mocking their own president
you have political leaders who are
actually suggesting than certain
segments of the American population of
US citizens aren't as sort of legitimate
and deserving as other segments whatever
your political beliefs surely that is an
insult to our shared idea of democracy
inequality and when soldiers go overseas
to fight for those ideals and come home
to watch a country that can't agree on
them and in fact is endangering itself
through this behavior it must be
incredibly demoralizing and again I'm
not a psychologist but I know a lot of
soldiers who have gone through a lot of
stuff and I've gone through a lot of
stuff with them and I imagine that along
with the other psychological stresses
that come with combat there's this other
horrible psychological stress that
happens when they return home
and they see what we're doing to each
other and if only for their sake I wish
we'd stop it